auftritt der band helmut shaker es ist
das erste mal dass während der berlin
music week auf straßen konzerte
stattfinden
für die künstler eine gute möglichkeit
bekannter zu werden dass sie künftig
auch von streaming ihrer songs leben
können das bezweifeln sie einmal nicht
viel eher der live-auftritt damit
verdienen wir unser geld streaming
gehört zu einer generation für die alles
umsonst ist das geld wird hier verdient
bei streaming-diensten with music das
norwegische startup ist inzwischen in
fünf europäischen ländern präsent und
startet demnächst auch in den usa und
großbritannien
die redaktion will kunden mit beratung
und zusätzlichen informationen zu
künstlern und bands locken und sie
bietet hifi qualität an
damit will das startup aus jazz und
klassik fans überzeugen die
streaming-dienste bisher nicht besonders
stark nutzen
ein solches abonnement kostet 20 euro im
monat das meiste davon geht an die
plattenfirmen
wir geben fast wie all die anderen
streaming service ist bis zu 70 der
kompletten einnahmen an die labels ab
also quasi abhängig davon was die devise
verträge haben aber das sind halt 65 bis
70 prozent mehr ist auch fast gar nicht
möglich was bei den künstlern ankommt
das können wir dann natürlich dann
leider nicht diktieren
und genau das ärgert die musiker auf der
berlin music week
ob streaming für die bands auch mal eine
goldgrube wird noch kann davon nicht die
rede sein denn post riem so heißt es
fließen nur zwischen 0,6 und 0,8 cent an
den künstler
diese sind daher immer stärker auf
einnahmen durch live-konzerte angewiesen
dieser ökonomische druck natürlich auf
die ganze branche der wächst ganz extrem
weil klar wird ihnen war mit tonträgern
oder mit streamings nicht mehr so viel
wie früher das heißt man muss seine
kohle eigentlich mit diesem ganzen
festival zirkus im sommer machen da gibt
es aber auch enorme verdrängungsprozesse
denn je
selbst dieser zirkus ist bis war nicht
sehr lukrativ auf der music week etwa
finden mehrere festivals parallel statt
viele künstler treten bei diesen
gelegenheiten inzwischen für sehr
geringe oder gar keine gagen auf um
bekannter zu werden und dann vielleicht
entsprechend oft im internet gestreamt
zu werden viele immerhin eine gute
werbung für eine eventuelle spätere cd